[Applaudissements]
question c'est vrai parce que moi je
peux rentrer du boulot derrière monsieur
isabelle ils ont tous dit tout à l'heure
que quand vous aimiez vous inondée de
textos et d'appels le week-end moi je ne
reçois jamais rien j'en tire les
conséquences
oui alors ça veut rien dire y'a pas de
questions ces orages en tirer les
conséquences et que vous ne l'aimez pas
non mais vous ne répondez jamais au
téléphone et c'est vrai je vous jure que
c'est vrai ne répond jamais au téléphone
alors je tombe sur son répondeur qui est
insupportable
j'vous l'dit son répondeur est
insupportable et je ne veux pas tomber
sur votre répondeur vous voulez je vous
appelle pour qu'on écoute votre
répondeur
oui il est tellement relou son épouse
heures mais je ne peux pas le voir je
vous le faire écouter certains points
communs avec ma mère alors est ce que
vous voulez alors john lennon mais je
vous jure
regardez je vais l'appeler il est
insupportable son répondeur dont il
faudrait que vous ne répondez jamais
donc donc forcément je ne vous appelle
pas alors que les autres et nora mathieu
texto que on reconnaît la fin mon avis
la tension que nous portent serré qui a
dans le texto regardez regardez
j'appelle isabelle morini bosc
écoutez bien sauver sa messagerie garder
comme les rôles répondait pas
[Musique]
on comprend mieux la c'est mon kiné
c'est un jour où j'enregistre et de
message vocal comme le kiné maman qui
n'est mon meilleur ami se sont amusés à
polluer le message seveso l'air très
sympa merci les allées